Fire And Blood will reign again and you can
expect to see the Blackfyre Rebellions in
the later seasons of House of the Dragon,
which thus of course inludes legendary Bittersteel
as well,
the man behind almost every Blackfyre Rebellion.
The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on the George
RR Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself. Later
seasons however, will be based on George RR
Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume
2 book .
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
One of the key characters and according to
some,
the true mastermind behind the Blackfyre Rebellions
was Bittersteel.
Ser Aegor Rivers, frequently called Bittersteel,
was one of the infamous four Great Bastards
and a son of a King Aegon IV Targaryen, also
known as "Aegon the Unworthy".
The four Great Bastards were Daemon Blackfyre
(whose mother, secretly, was Daena Targaryen),
Aegor "Bittersteel" Rivers (whose mother was
a member of House Bracken),
Brynden "Bloodraven" Rivers (whose mother
was a member of House Blackwood),
and Shiera Seastar (whose mother was Serenei
of Lys, from an ancient Valyrian noble family).
On his deathbed, Aegon IV foolishly (and perhaps
spitefully) had them all legitimized,
which led to strife between them and his legitimate
heir King Daeron II,
tensions which ultimately split the realm
apart in the devastating civil war known as
the Blackfyre Rebellion. Aegor was a Blackfyre
loyalist and the founder of a famed group
of exiled sellswords,
the Golden Company composed primarily of Westerosi
exiles. In his personal arms, he combined
the red stallion of House Bracken with black
dragon wings from House Blackfyre, on a golden
field.
Being a half-Targaryen, Aegor had purple eyes,
but black hair.
He looked like a warrior, being lean, light,
and tall. Aegor's armor was well-made, although
plain-looking, being grey-steel and black
rings. On his helm was a horse head with a
horse's mane flowing behind. His shield displayed
his personal sigil: a stallion with black
dragon wings, on a golden field, snorting
fire.
Aegor was angry all of his life, and quickly
irritated and offended. He did not smile,
and especially loathed his younger half-brother,
Brynden Rivers known as the Bloodraven.
Aegor was born at King's Landing to one of
King Aegon IV Targaryen's mistresses, Barba
Bracken.
When Queen Naerys Targaryen recovered her
health,
Prince Daeron and Aemon the Dragonknight forced
Aegon to send Barba and child from the capital,
and Aegor was instead raised at Stone Hedge
in the riverlands.
Aegor loathed Brynden even further when Shiera
Seastar, their beautiful half-sister
and a fellow Great Bastard, chose Brynden
over him.
Bloodraven asked her to marry him dozens of
times and she refused,
but she did let him into her bed - although
she had many lovers. Shiera, however, completely
rejected Bittersteel, and for this he never
forgave Bloodraven.
It also did not help that Bittersteel's mother
was a Bracken
and Bloodraven's mother was a Blackwood, as
those two noble families had been feuding
for thousands of years.
Bittersteel became a great champion and general
for the Blackfyres,
while Bloodraven became a great champion and
general for the Targaryens.
Their other half-brother, Daemon Blackfyre,
agreed to wed his daughter Calla to Aegor.
Aegor often urged Daemon to press his own
claim to the Iron Throne.
''Bittersteel and Bloodraven both loved Shiera
Seastar, and the Seven Kingdoms bled.''
are thoughts of Ser Barristan Selmy, indicating
that the true reason behind Bittersteel persuing
Daemon to rebel against their Targaryen half-brother,
was just so he could fight and kill Bloodraven.
In the First Blackfyre Rebellion in 196 AC,
Aegor was the right hand of Daemon Blackfyre
against King Daeron II Targaryen. In addition,
it's rumored he convinced Daemon to start
the rebellion.
During the battle of the Redgrass Field, Aegor
commanded the right of Daemon's host.
To prevent a rout upon Daemon's death during
the battle, Aegor rallied his troops and charged
into the Raven's Teeth, the archers of Brynden
Rivers, who just killed Daemon and his sons.
Although Aegor took out Bloodraven's eye during
their duel,
he ultimately fled the battlefield when the
Targaryen reinforcement came and the deafeat
was certain.
Carrying the Valyrian steel sword Blackfyre,
Aegor fled Westeros with Daemon's widow,
Rohanne of Tyrosh, and her surviving children,
eventually settling in the Free City of Tyrosh.
While in the Free Cities, Aegor served a year
with the Second Sons before leaving
to create the Golden Company, a famous mercenary
organization, to stop the loss of support
for the Blackfyres as many of Bittersteel's
remaining men deserted to join mercenary companies.
In response, Bittersteel resorted to forming
his remaining soldiers into their own mercenary
company, called the Golden Company. Wars cost
money and Aegor Rivers, the leader of the
Blackfyre forces, decided he could sell his
army's services to other lords while waiting
to return to Westeros.
The Golden Company was born.
Day by day and year by year they fought in
petty wars between different Free Cities in
order to make enough money for their basic
upkeep. This step at least ensured
that the Blackfyre Pretenders would have some
semblance of a stable core fighting force
whenever they mounted a new plot to invade
Westeros.
While sellswords are notoriously unreliable,
the Golden Company has a respectable reputation.
They are said to have never broken a contract.
The words of the Golden Company are "Beneath
the gold, the bitter steel", and refer to
Aegor's nickname, Bittersteel,
to remind themselves that they are not just
sellswords,
but knights of the Seven Kingdoms who will
one day retake their home.
Shortly after its creation, and under Aegor's
command, the Golden Company became one of
the most famous and disciplined sellsword
companies known in the Free Cities. They quickly
established their reputation by sacking Qohor
when the city refused to honor its contract.
From the Free Cities, Bittersteel continued
to plot new invasions of the Seven Kingdoms
for at least forty years. The Golden Company
was heavily involved in three of the four
Blackfyre Rebellions that followed the first
one. After the first (and greatest) rebellion
failed in 196 AC,
he took no part in the Second Blackfyre Rebellion
in 212 AC - which was more of a failed plot
than an actual war - which was instigated
by Daemon II Blackfyre. Daemon was kept in
captivity rather than executed with the other
rebel leaders, ensuring that Aegor Rivers
could not name his brother Haegon as a serious
pretender. However, Daemon died a few years
later while a hostage in the Red Keep,
and Haegon and Bittersteel launched the Third
Blackfyre Rebellion.
While Aegor refused to support Daemon II Blackfyre
during the Second Blackfyre Rebellion in 211
AC,
he supported Haegon I Blackfyre in the Third
Blackfyre Rebellion in 219 AC.
During one of the various Blackfyre Rebellions,
Aegor swore a blood oath with Torwyn Greyjoy,
but this Lord Reaper of Pyke betrayed Aegor
to his enemies.
Aegor was captured at the end of the third
rebellion, and was briefly taken captive after
the failure of the Third Blackfyre Rebellion,
and brought to the Red Keep in chains.
He was found guilty of high treason, and while
Bloodraven and Prince Aerion urged King Aerys
I Targaryen to execute Bittersteel, Aerys
instead chose to send him to the Wall;
however, Aegor's allies captured the ship
transporting him to Eastwatch-by-the-Sea
and freed him to return to Essos and to the
Golden Company.
In Tyrosh, before the year was over, Aegor
crowned Daemon III Blackfyre, Haegon I's eldest
son.
In 236 AC, Aegor landed on Westeros at the
head of the Golden Company with Daemon III,
starting the Fourth Blackfyre Rebellion. By
this time, however, they had very little support.
The rebellion was crushed at the battle of
Wendwater Bridge, although Aegor managed to
escape.
Daemon III Blackfyre was personally killed
by Ser Duncan the Tall in battle and the rebellion
ended.
This was the last Blackfyre rebellion Aegor's
participated in,
but there was one more, named the War of the
Ninepenny Kings.
A few years after the Wendwater Bridge, Aegor
reappeared in the Disputed Lands,
where he fell during a skirmish between Tyrosh
and Myr.
On his deathbed, he commanded the men of the
Golden Company to boil the flesh from his
skull,
dip it in gold, and carry it before them when
they cross the narrow sea to retake Westeros.
Beneath the gold, the bitter steel, indeed.
The captains-general who have since led the
Golden Company have followed Aegor's example.
Legendary characters such as Bittersteel,
Daemon Blackfyre, the Dragonknight
and a dozen more legendary characters coming
before in the Dance of the Dragons
and after in Roberts Rebellion, legendary
battles such as each Blackfyre Rebellion
and many more coming before and after as well,
especially all the battles in the Targaryen
civil war,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel show, House of the Dragon, brings
in 2022 on HBO.
Thank you so much for watching, I hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one. Peace!